failing to connect to EA servers it's
not just you if he has numerous EA games
not just the battlefield 1 beta as first
reported are experiencing today's issues
while you wait for the service come back
online join us for this frustrating
games hot news updates with the
battlefield 1 beta opening up to
everyone today the game is experiencing
server issues for a large number of
players after a fairly smooth rollout
yesterday the issues began popping up as
a much wider pool of people allowed in
players looking to jump into the game
unable to connect to EA servers
presenting them with a screen that reads
failed to connect to Iran line on top of
that a number of individual games of
also reported problems and the EA
support Twitter account said the message
EA is currently experiencing an outage
EA games services and support may be
impacted we are working to resolve as
fast as possible a number of us at games
but are running into the issue on both
xbox one and pc the outages have spawned
and lengthy thread on the battlefield
forum with people reporting they are
unable to connect on all platforms
including ps4 the bow field want open
beta officially begins today after
yesterday's early access period and as
of yet no day for when it will be
finished has been announced so are you
excited about filled one assuming the
server issues will let you play it let
us know in the comment section below or
find me on Twitter at irregular Dave and
for all your battlefield news stay tuned
to gamespot com